thank you so much it's really an honor
and a pleasure to be here tonight I'll
tell you just a little bit about the
piece that we're going to play Bob
mentioned that we make really large
bizarre instruments and things is one of
the first gigs I've ever been at where
we don't have the largest most bizarre
instrument here it's really kind of
shocking and and actually it's been very
moving to see that music has been a
common thread through the evening
tonight here we are at MIT in a
neuroscience building and yet music has
been playing almost the whole time we're
ending the evening with music and partly
that's because we all love music and and
MIT values it very much that's moving in
itself but I think we also have the
intuition that music is somehow special
as all the arts are and that it taps
into the deepest parts of us as human
beings we think about the neurosciences
music is one of the most mysterious
things that exist we have absolutely no
idea you can't read a book about why
music moves us the way it does why music
brings memories back to us the way it
does and you can look every day in the
paper we see new evidence that music is
the last thing that Alzheimer's patients
respond to and it's one of the very few
things that stroke patients with aphasia
it can recover their speech one of the
very few things that people who've lost
movement through strokes can learn to
move again we don't know why that is but
one of the things one of the most
important things for the arts to do
right now is to work with the
neurosciences to understand that both
for the knowledge and also so that we
can use the arts as one of the tools to
help help people with many many
different disabilities so as as
musicians we are here to to participate
in help with work in this wonderful
center because it's the biggest
challenge ahead the piece we're going to
play is called Judah the first version
of this piece I created last summer for
the Boston Pops we the Boston Pops were
dying to come here tonight the stage was
a little small so we couldn't fit them
in so we made a new version especially
for this evening and Michael chertok is
playing this piano we've taken an
opposite approach from the instruments
over here
I've taken a regular piano and the piano
itself does all kinds of special things
they're sensors in the piano so that
when Michael plays the piano knows what
he's playing and how he's playing it
knows which notes how loud they're
played how long they're played and
they're also motors inside the piano so
that the computer can send instructions
to the piano and play notes even when
his fingers are gone the notes so in
fact the way the piece works is that
Michael plays and often depending on how
he plays he might go drew room and then
the piano takes over and goes boom like
that and for those of you who were
sitting on this side fact we angled it
perfectly so president Hockfield can see
the keyboard just right so if you're if
you're sitting over there you'll
actually have quite a show because
you'll see the piano responding to
Michael but besides that for this
evening to replace the Boston Pops I
added another layer of special sounds
that come in in the middle of the piece
and add to the piano and other special
treat is that on this screen there's a
set of images absolutely spectacular
images that not only illustrate the
piece but respond to the music the music
itself and how Michael plays it it live
those images were made by Mark down Ikki
understand up mark mark just finished
his PhD at the Media Lab is one of those
disgustingly talented MIT students who's
one of the best programmers around
fantastic visual artists and have us to
be darned at a really good composer also
all three but he made these images that
reflect the feeling of the piece and
respond exactly how he plays Mike Fabio
who's a grad student at the Media Lab
wrote the software that does all the
magic for the music
so we'd like to play this piece for you
called judo it's just about 10 minutes
long and this is a brand-new version
which we dedicate to the McGovern
Institute and to patent Lori McGovern
you
you
I